what we're going to do in this video is
demonstrate that angles are congruent if
and only if they have the same measure
and for our definition of congruence we
will use the rigid transformation
definition which tells us two figures
are congruent if and only if there
exists a series of rigid transformations
which will map one figure onto the other
and then what are rigid transformations
those are transformations that preserve
distance between points and angle
measures
so let's get to it so let's start with
two angles that are congruent and i'm
going to show that they have the same
measure i'm going to demonstrate that so
they start
congruent
so these two angles are congruent to
each other
now this means by the rigid
transformation definition of congruence
there
is a series
of rigid transformations
transformations
that
map
angle a
b c
onto
angle i'll do it here onto angle
def
by definition
by definition of rigid transformations
they
preserve angle measure
preserve
angle measure
so if you're able to map the left angle
onto the right angle and in doing so you
did it with transformations that
preserved angle measure they must now
have the same angle measure
we now know that the measure of angle a
b c is equal to the measure of angle d e
f
so we've demonstrated this green
statement the first way that if things
are congruent they will have the same
measure now let's prove it the other way
around
so now let's start with the idea that
measure of angle a
b c
is equal to the measure of angle d e f
and to demonstrate that these are going
to be congruent we just have to show
that there's always a series of rigid
transformations that will map angle abc
onto angle def
and to help us there let's just
visualize these angles
so
draw this really fast angle a
b
c
an angle is defined by two rays that
start at a point that point is the
vertex
so that's a b c and then let me draw
angle
d e f
so it might look something like this d
e
f
and what we will now do is let's do our
first rigid transformation
let's translate
translate
angle a
b c
so
that
b
mapped
to point e and if we did that so we're
going to translate it like that
then abc is going to look something like
abc is going to look something like this
it's going to look something like this b
is now mapped on to e
this would be
where a would get mapped to this would
where c would get mapped to sometimes
you might see a notation a prime c prime
and this is where b would get mapped to
and then the next thing i would do is i
would rotate
angle a
b c
about
its vertex about b
so
that
ray bc
ray bc
coincides
coincides
with
ray ef
now you so you're just going to rotate
the whole angle that way so that now
ray bc coincides with ray ef well you
might be saying hey c doesn't
necessarily have to sit on f because
they might be different distances from
their vertices but that's all right the
ray can be defined by any point that
sits on that ray so now if you do this
rotation and the end ray bc coincides
with ray ef now those two rays would be
equivalent because
measure of angle a b c is equal to the
measure of angle d e f
that will also tell us that ray
b a
ray b a
now
coincides
coincides
with
ray ed
and just like that i've given you a
series of rigid transformations that
will always work if you translate so
that the vertices are mapped onto each
other and then you rotate it so that the
bottom ray of one angle coincides with
the bottom ray of the other angle then
you could say the top ray of the two
angles will now coincide because the
angles have the same measure and because
of that the angles now completely
coincide and so we know that angle a b c
is congruent to angle d e f and we're
now done we've proven
both sides of the statement if they're
congruent they have the same measure if
they have the same measure then they are
congruent